the eu is prepared to impose sanctions
on russia including its gas exports if
ukraine is invaded russell van der lion
has been speaking to our diplomatic
editor james bayes at the munich
security conference
everything is on the table this is very
clear and for us was important and we
have managed to do that to be prepared
in case that there is a russian
decoupling disruption of supply of gas
to the european union we've reached out
to all our friends around the globe to
diversify the supply and we were
successful we had now the highest
lng supply ever in january and as of
today i can say we are on the safe side
what this winter is concerned just to be
clear what you just said everything's on
the table so energy imports swift
banking system nordstrom still not
decided whether those will be included
the final decision will be taken in case
that russia is
beginning a war against ukraine any
military aggression against ukraine and
then it's going to be a political
decision by the european council that is
taken but the preparation for the
preparation everything is on the table